le théâtre en compagnie de michel
piccoli qui est ce soir notre invité en
direct de nanterre bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous allons nous arrêter quelques
minutes sur une pièce de shakespeare le
conte d'hiver pièce qui sera jouée à
partir du 8 mars prochain au théâtre des
amandiers à nanterre précisément le
conte d'hiver est l'une des dernières
pièces de shakespeare certains affirment
que c'est la plus belle
on y découvre tour à tour la jalousie la
tragédie la violence l'amour
l'extrait que vous allez voir se situe
au tout début de la pièce
à l'instant où l'univers du roi de
sicile incarné par michel piccoli est en
train de complètement basculé reportage
de michel strelok ici et christian
héraud chimie de la répétition pour un
conte magique
la jalousie ou mise en scène michel
piccoli un roi emporter par la folie
la déchirure dans tous ses états alors
vous avez sud est je suis jaloux
pour tous chevaux si donc je résume
parler d'offre
la première pour retenir mont royal
époux pour toujours la deuxième pour
retenir un ami pour rennes est un geste
un seul geste et le monde bascule la
trahison est là au coeur du bonheur mais
la jalousie est un phénomène énigmatique
quand même je dirais et oui parce que et
quand deux camps commence-t-elle
quel est son quelle est son origine est
ce qu elle existe elle est pré existante
ou est-ce qu'il faut quelque chose pour
faire provoquer la jalousie
personne ne le sait encore et ces pièces
non plus elle fait pas semblant de
savoir mais elle la montre dans c'est
dans ces moments les plus étouffant et
violent pense est dramatique
je n'ai mal avant que mon coeur d'un
seul but ce n'est pas de joie non pas du
tout on peut tranquillement montré de
l'hospitalité il n'y a rien à dire à
cela de la gentillesse des attentions de
l'intimité
tout cela est correct mais de là à se
fouler les paumes à se passer les doigts
ils sont en train de le faire avec ce
pays comme dans un miroir et s'écrit de
biche à l'agonie à